now then the World Economic Forum takes
place in Davos this week why should you
care well it's billed as a meeting of
minds a melting pot of business politics
and sheer raw power so is it a force for
good or just a closed Club for the rich
powerful and famous I'm joined now by a
seasoned attendee who's worked in both
business and politics she's of course
the former White House adviser now
president of principle is asset
management dr. Pippa malmgren very good
morning to you going this year how many
times have you been well I was one of
the young leaders so I was privileged to
go when I was very young and and for
some years after that I mean it's an
amazing event because there are so many
people that we know are that are there
and they're all talking about big issues
my personal view is that since the media
started being so present there they no
longer can say anything really
interesting it's all sort of a lot of
grandstanding having said that people
are reminded of big issues that as chief
executives that kind of put to the side
sometimes so it serves a good purpose oh
it's already young leaders a minute
earlier it's all about the oldest events
there mean it looks on the outside like
a closed shop you see Bill Clinton
joshing with Bono and George Clooney and
everyone goes Oh Deary Deary well what
are you achieve that's not overlook the
fact that you pay tens of thousands of
pounds for a seat it's an expensive
thing to go to but on the other hand
again what they've done is created an
interest in that kind of topic and so
many things have come out of it like the
TED Talks and so many different
organizations that now bring together
talking heads to have conversations
about important issues so the spin-offs
from Davos have been quite impressive so
you're saying look at the whole iceberg
not just the tip of the iceberg we see
but it's did their own fault making it a
closed shop we know how carefully they
controlled a boss you know who's allowed
I mean security is obviously an issue
you know they control who gets access to
do yeah no question about it and I think
Vito they like the huge publicity and
the controversy but everyone always says
what did they accomplish at Davos and
the answer is there is no output you
know they don't produce anything
sometimes deals get announced there that
we're already in motion but again I
guess the purpose of it is to
to create a forum for a conversation
about the things that matter but do they
do anything about it like we live in a
world where inequality is obviously
hitting record highs right wages is a
percentage of GDP record low profits
record high what can they do about it
Davos but individually chief executives
can address this issue well what about
these young leaders that you are you
were part of their I mean you know
that's that's for the future is it
useful enter these young leaders to get
access to to some of the old leaders
cover their thoughts what was really
interesting is as a young leader you
didn't get much access all guys but what
you did get was access to each other and
there is nothing better than being
exposed to people here at the cutting
edge of a field entirely different from
your own that is so inspiring of new
ideas so I have to say that was a
jewelry stay in touch I mean he's not me
dude oh yeah it's like an alumni and we
get together we go drinking and we talk
about what's going on in the world but
the problem then again it seems to those
on the outside that this is behind
closed doors these are people who have
access to power they're talking to each
other secretly about things that may
affect our lives shouldn't we know about
it and shall we have a say about it well
I think the public does have a say in
all these important issues and there are
lots of ways to express your view that's
just one form out of many and to be fair
I think davos makes an effort to bring
in regular people if they are at the
cutting edge of their field in other
words you don't have to be a chief
executive you could be the leading voice
on a particular issue but still yeah is
it an elitist shop definitely do you
think it needs reform do you think the
things that they should do to signal
this unit a sense of openness and
accountability yeah you know at the end
of the day it's a business right it's
it's a profit generating business so
they have to run it in whatever way
actually achieves that end but the
question is what can we do to create
more forums where the public can get
engaged in issues and again we live in
such a great world where we have things
like Twitter and you know people can
talk in public forums about the things
that are on their minds so should we
regard it more I mean like a literary
festival i'm thinking of behavior time
fest earlier where you get the great new
good there you know talking about books
and things like that but behind the
scenes
they're treated like that rather than
the conspiracy theorists some kind of
sinister world leaders exactly so I
belong to all of the clubs that are
considered the sinister conspiracy
theory clubs Council Foreign Relations
Chatham House here in London the
institute for international strategic
studies yeah and everybody goes whole
you know this is a closed shop of
elitist and then you go to the meetings
and they're kind of boring and nobody's
saying anything all that interesting
anything you'll come on there's so many
interesting issues can we not get at the
heart of the matter the point is even
when you have the most powerful people
in the room it doesn't mean they have
the answers I mean what evers the white
house everybody is to say sir surely you
know the answer and you know what you
don't know okay baby thanks for the
insight as always babe evolving they're
very good to see